"- Abbas by Abbas!
- Et à ton avis, pourquoi
je le fais ce documentaire?
- Si les autres sont riches,
c’est pas de leur faute,
ils sont riches, ils sont riches.
- La grande Histoire et
nos petites histoires personnelles
se sont retrouvées
intimement liées. "
Ça fait 20 ans
qu’il y a des docs sur LCP.
Ça représente plus de
1500 documentaires en 20 ans.
250 docs inédits
qu’on a vus que sur LCP.
On est une jolie lucarne,
à 20h30
pour des films qui passeraient
peut-être à minuit trente
ou une heure du matin ailleurs.
" Mon Chirac,
ce n'est pas un personnage ordinaire. "
Celui qui a fait le plus d’audience,
c’était Mon Chirac,
peut-être aussi parce que justement,
on ne s’attendait pas à voir
Jean-Louis Debré documentariste.
" Je sais pas qui est Chirac.
Je sais pas vraiment. "
Un documentaire, c’est un miroir
du monde dans lequel on est.
Ça fait écho finalement
à toutes les thématiques,
les sujets qui sont discutés,
traités dans l’Assemblée.
" Mes parents, ils ont dit
la nourriture passe avant tout.
Ce qui est logique.
Ils me disent toujours :
à la fin du mois
tu préfères manger
des jouets ou du steak?
Ben je réponds du steak,
mais ça m’enquiquine un peu,
parce que des fois j’ai envie de jouer. "
Ça avait suscité une telle émotion,
il y a eu un tel écho chez les téléspectateurs
qu’on était assaillis de paquets
de jouets à l’accueil de LCP!
" Photographe,
c’est du Grec,
c’est celui qui écrit
avec la lumière. "
Abbas by Abbas, c’est l’histoire
d’un photographe franco-iranien.
Ses photos, vous les avez
certainement toutes vues,
en noir et blanc, magnifiques,
de l’Apartheid à la révolution iranienne.
" J’étais tellement près de lui
que j’étais obligé de reculer comme ça
pour pouvoir le photographier,
le cadrer.
Je crois que la photo
parle d’elle-même, voilà. "
Et c’est le seul film
qui nous a été acheté par la BBC
donc là aussi grande fierté.
" Ça va mieux quand
on enlève le bouchon! "
Ce n’est plus une petite chaîne
parmi tant d’autres
comme on pouvait l’être
il y a 20 ans.
C’est vrai qu’on a aussi grandi,
on s’est affirmé
on est devenu
une belle chaîne.
Et ça attire et ça donne envie
à des documentaristes de grand nom
des signatures comme William Karel
de faire un film, que pour LCP.
On serre le budget,
on ne va peut-être pas faire
une marge de dingue
mais on va faire
un film qui va exister
qui va avoir une belle exposition.
C'est ça qui est génial à LCP,
c’est que la passion,
l’envie de faire ce film,
de raconter cette histoire
ça balaie toutdonc
c’est vrai que c’est rare !